Speaker 1: It's great to have back on the
program today, Nicholas Christakis Sterling,
professor of Social Natural Science at
Yale University, also author of the book
Apollo's Arrow The Profound and Enduring
Impact of Coronavirus on the Way We Live
Now out as of last month in paperback
with a bunch of new material still very,
very accurate. Great to have you back on.
Speaker 2: Thank you so much for having me,
David. It's good to be back on.
Speaker 1: So last time we spoke.
January of this year. It was very early
in the vaccine rollout. You and I spoke
a little bit about the societal impact that the
pandemic had had. To that point, maybe to kind
of get us into the conversation today. Are you
surprised at the degree of partizanship in the
adoption of vaccinations since you and I last
spoke? Or is it in line with what you expected?
Speaker 2: No. The partizanship and the sort of
ideological way we have approached many aspects
of the upper end of the pandemic has surprised
me a little bit, to be honest. I mean, I like
the fact that we live in a plural democracy.
You know, we do not live in a monarchy or no,
not talk or see, you're in some kind of a society
where everyone has the same opinions, either
because they're forced to or naturally, we live in
a society with a tremendous amount of ideological
diversity, which I find healthy regardless
of what part of the spectrum you are on.
And one of the other things that's a feature of
our society is that we resolve our disputes not by
force of arms, but by voting. So we when we vote,
that's how we, you know, come to trust a consensus
and. But what's interesting to me? So so I like
the fact that we have this ideological diversity.
But what perplexes me is that we have we are
increasingly or at least in the setting of the
pandemic, we seem to be expressing our ideological
diversity via our response to the pandemic. And
that's weird. In other words, if you believe in
a cause or in a candidate, get a bumper sticker,
get a lawn sign. I mean, use a conventional
means of signaling your political identity
to signal your political identity by whether
you wear a mask or not. Or by whether you get
vaccinated or not strikes me as foolish. It is
taking something which should be just technocratic
and just, you know, non-ideological and making
it into something that's ideological. And I think
that as a nation that has harmed us tremendously,
we always had some vaccine hesitancy typically
that originated on the far left actually prior
to this pandemic. Now we have a far right group
that is it has a lot of vaccine hesitancy. We
and the people that are vaccine hesitant are
are a heterogeneous mix of people. Some political
motivations. Others have other sort of. You
would say more sensible concerns, like they're
worried the vaccines were developed too swiftly,
or some have conspiracy ideas which are easy
to rebut. You know, they're just false. I mean,
they may they may not listen to you when you
were about them, but they are patently false.
There aren't little micro magnetic chips in the
vaccines and so on. So. So it's a problem. Vaccine
hesitancy is a problem. The politicization of our
response is a problem, and it's a problem not just
for those individuals, but also for our society.
Speaker 1: When you look at that combined with,
I mean, I think another issue to to to choose
one other issue to talk about and then we'll
kind of tie them together. Another thing
that's going on in a lot of the discussions
of what the path forward is are sometimes kind of
inaccurate assessments of the base levels of risk
prior to the pandemic. And, you know, in a typical
flu season, you would see about 100 people per day
die of the flu over the course of the year. Now
it's concentrated over flu season, so it's not
literally 100 per day. But you know, we're now
at a thousand or so. And so we kind of are trying
to think about how do we evaluate the level of
risk that would be acceptable to quote, go back
to normal and everybody has a different metric
that they might be using. Some people are saying
the fact that now we need a third dose and
they're talking about fourth doses, that's
making me kind of throw in the towel and say,
I'm going back to normal now because otherwise
it seems like I maybe never will. Other folks are
saying, Well, until we really don't need masks,
I am going to live life one way. And then when
the masks aren't needed, I'm going to quote,
go back to normal. Others are looking at
case numbers, et cetera. What is your general
assessment of the metrics by which we should be
thinking about going back to normal and even what
it means to go back to normal at this point?
Speaker 2: Well, I do discuss all this in in
in the book in Apollo's Arrow, but but let me
try to take a stab at that. I think the first
thing I would do is to step back and have a high
order understanding that people need to understand
that our world has changed. There's something
new about the world. It was not there two years
ago. It's a deadly virus. It's it's not as bad as
smallpox or bubonic plague or cholera, but it's
not like influenza or chicken pox. It kills this
virus, kills about one percent of the people that
it infects. That's a pretty serious pathogen.
That's a that's a serious virus. And that virus
was not there before. And now it is there. You can
think of it like sort of radioactive rain that is,
you know, making every surface toxic or something.
It is. It's a new feature of our environment. And
I think the idea that we could just pretend
it's not there is wrongheaded. Now there's
also some wisdom in accepting the new reality
that is to say, Well, the world has changed.
It's that sucks, but let's just accept it.
And I understand that point of view. But I
also think it's important to understand that we
have over seven hundred and fifty thousand of our
fellow citizens that have died in the last
year and a half because of this pandemic,
and probably as many as a million will ultimately
die. And that is a catastrophic loss of life.
You know, hundreds of thousands of our fellow
citizens have died five times as many will be
disabled by this virus, that people who survive,
they don't have long or short COVID, they get over
their COVID, but now their bodies are harmed. They
have they have a pulmonary fibrosis or adrenal
insufficiency or or cardiac or neurologic or
psychiatric problems as a result of the virus. So
five million Americans will have that, plus 10
times as many people as die will be grieving the
death of a loved one. That's another 10 million
Americans. And and so there are lots and lots of
our fellow citizens who are going to suffer
from this condition. And I think it doesn't
serve us well to just whistle by the graveyard
and pretend nothing is is happening. Something
is happening and it's not a trivial thing that's
happening. And so it is right for us to consider
how to cope with it. Now we are approaching
the end of the immediate phase of the epidemic
when we reach this herd immunity threshold
sometime in 2022 that our country will get there.
But as the Omicron variant has illustrated,
the whole world has to get there because now
new variants are going to come, you see, and
could potentially cause more problems. But
what you need to think about it is unless
you're a hermit. Or you're very lucky.
Either you will get vaccinated with this
condition or you'll be infected by the
that those are your choices at some point.
Yeah, yeah, you're going to get the vaccine or
you're going to get vaccinated or both. And and
getting the disease naturally unvaccinated, you
have about a one percent chance of dying, getting
vaccinated, you about a one in a million chance of
dying. So it is. From the vaccine. So it is it
is a no brainer what the rational choice should
be in terms of those those two alternatives and
Speaker 1: where can you go back to that just
for clarity? One in a million chance of dying
from the vaccine? So the latest I've seen is,
you know, these these three cases of myocarditis
after the vaccine that led to death, where is one
in a million coming from? I've not heard that.
Speaker 2: I'm saying it's less than one. Oh,
I'm sorry. Less than OK. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, the order one in a million other words,
what we from a public health point of view,
we we didn't. We always tolerate some risk of
death from vaccines, right? Yes, you give
a vaccine, you saved ten thousand lives
and you lose one life. And you know, that's a
tradeoff that you make with any public policy,
you know, sure. With how you build your robes or
how you secure the safety of your factories. These
are always issues like there's some downside and
there's some upside, and you want the upside to be
vastly higher than the downside, which it is with
vaccines. So these vaccines, these coronavirus
vaccines are exceedingly safe as vaccines go
far, surpassing typical standards. And and
it's they're far better than getting the disease
naturally, which, you know, poses a risk of death.
Anyway, the point is that everyone is going to
either get vaccinated or get the disease and
and and when that happens, then we will
have reached this herd immunity threshold,
which will be sometime in the next
few months in our society. This is
assuming we don't get new, worrisome strains of
the virus that can evade the vaccines or otherwise
are more deadly, for example, which could muck
up the works of what I'm saying. But anyway,
so we're going to get to that point soon. And
I think that is going to be one landmark of
when we can return to normal now. We're not
going to immediately return to normal because
think about it this way, it's like a tsunami
washes up ashore and devastates the countryside.
Well, eventually the water recedes. That's great.
You know, the sea level has returned to normal,
but the countryside is devastated, right? There's
a huge mess that needs to be cleaned up. And
that's a little bit of what's going to happen
to us. You know, when when we pass into the
intermediate phase of the pandemic after
we reach this herd immunity threshold.
We're going to have had millions of children that
miss school. Millions of our fellow citizens that
are disabled, as we just said, tens of millions
that are grieving the loss of loved ones.
Millions of people who've lost their
jobs. Millions of businesses that have
gone out of business. We were borrowing
trillions of dollars against the future
to kind of soften the blow. Right now, we
have to repay those debts. All of that is
still going to affect us. You know, it's not going
to be like a sudden, Oh, we're just back to normal
again. So that's going to take some time as well.
Anyway, I think I understand people's desire to
return to normal. I understand the fatalism
that says, Well, what can you do? The world
has changed. Is this awful virus? But I would say
that we don't need to tolerate needless deaths.
You know, just because a fire is raging doesn't
mean you need to say, Well, when these fires rage,
many houses burn down and you know, what can you
do anyway? Know you're out there with your hose,
right? Hosing down your roof, and you're hoping
that your house doesn't burn down. And I think
those steps are prudent steps and steps we should
be making with respect to the pandemic as well.
Speaker 1: What are you not doing now that
you were doing before the pandemic? Like,
how have you set your level of
what you do and what you don't do?
Speaker 2: I. I'm not, as I do. First of all, I'm
vaccinated, and I would encourage people to get
the booster. There is some preliminary evidence
that the booster will also help with the Omicron
variant. Yes, as well. And although in general,
vaccine efficacy will decline, it declined when
the Delta variant came. So roughly speaking,
the vaccine was, let's say, 95 percent effective
against the original Wuhan strain of the
virus, maybe 90 percent. We're talking
about the many vaccines now 90 percent effective
against Delta, so lots of efficacy, but still
a 90 percent effective vaccine is a very
effective vaccine. That means if you if
you get infected with the virus, it'll lower
your risk of death by 90 percent, let's say.
Which is amazing. And probably it'll be lower
than that for Omicron with the existing vaccines
that the manufacturers are racing to produce
new customized versions of the vaccines. Yeah,
and we should, by the way, we should welcome
that. I don't think you should say, Oh, well,
I'll look at those pharma companies are trying
to get me to take more vaccines will know.
We're lucky that they can make these
vaccines just like tetanus. You know,
you get a tetanus shot every 10 years.
That's a prudent thing to do. Yeah, so
so. So I lost my train of thought in terms
Speaker 1: of what you're
not doing at this, what I'm
Speaker 2: doing, so I'm terribly vaccinated,
which is a sensible. I still wear a mask when I
go to crowded indoor environments with strangers.
I am seeing friends and family in my house
who I know to be vaccinated with, of course,
without masks. So I am resuming sort of small
scale social interactions with known individuals.
And I and I'm I'm minimizing some other things
like I don't travel as much as I used to. For
example, I don't, you know, I don't go to I do
go to indoor restaurants, but not as much as I
used to. You know, I'm just sort of I still
haven't fully, you know, resumed my previous
level of social interaction from prior to the
pandemic, unfortunately. And I look forward to
being able to honestly, I'm I'm fed up with this.
I find wearing a mask really tedious in yourself.
But I think it's a prudent precaution.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I know it sounds like it
sounds like you're basically doing what I'm doing.
And, you know, even with the indoor restaurants, I
was talking to my girlfriend the other day. I was
saying for me, I'm not doing this because people
wear a mask while they order and walk to the
table. I'm just evaluating, is it a really crowded
restaurant with tables close together? Not like
if it's not, I don't really care about the masks
to walk up to order. That seems, I don't know.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Plus you're young. Yeah. And
it's it's a it's a brief. You know,
you're only in the restaurant for an hour.
I mean, these are all the thing about
life during the time of a pandemic is that
it's all shades of gray. These are all relative
risks. There's no life with no risk. Yes.
And so, you know, you might, you know, going
to an indoor rock concert where people are
yelling and screaming for two and a half hours
with 20000 people is different than going with
your girlfriend to a hushed tones restaurant, you
know, for an hour. Yeah, it's different. And it's
different if you're 80 and immunocompromised and
if you're 30 and healthy, it's different. And so,
you know, I think I think if people are prepared
to think that way and understand that there are
degrees of risk and if they're also willing to do
their part right, this is the other thing that's
so irritating to me about the anti-vaxxers is
that to the extent that we all get vaccinated
quickly, then we can all resume normal life
more rapidly. Right? Get our vaccination
level up to 85 percent like the Portuguese
did, for example. You know, then we don't
we don't have to stay six feet apart anymore. When
we're go to, we go to the supermarket and we can
begin to resume or normal life. But yeah, in a way
we are. We are shooting ourselves in the foot by
not availing ourselves of this technology,
which, by the way, is one of the hallmarks
of American science and capitalism. I mean, we
are one of the things that upsets me is that.
Is that we did not bring our best game
to this fight? You know, the Chinese
are an authoritarian government and they have a
kind of collectivist culture and they use their
tools to cope with the virus. I would not be happy
to live in China under the constraints that are in
China. But those are the strengths the Chinese
had, and they, you know, they are effectively
controlling the epidemic. Now, we could not
have done that in the United States, but
we had money and science and we invented vaccines
very quickly. Why on earth wouldn't we use them?
Speaker 1: I think the biggest
advocates of the system that that
allowed that are now saying, I don't want it.
Speaker 2: Yes, it's odd, right? It's like,
it's like, you know, the and also it's a
little immature. Like, what do you expect?
You expect that your neighbors will
be dying from a contagious disease.
You're facing a risk of death from a contagious
disease, and nothing will be asked of you,
right? You know, really, you know, we're going
to have to pay more taxes. We're going to have
to run risk of death. We're going to have to
wear masks. We're going have to get vaccinated.
We're going to have to do a bunch of inconvenient
things because our world has changed. And I think
it's immature to sort of fantasize that nothing is
different now. Again, that's a different point I'm
making than the idea that at some point, we're
just going to have to accept it. But I hope we
would get to that acceptance point with the least
amount of death. Right. I see a lot of needless
death in our society right now, and it saddens me.
Speaker 1: So on Omicron briefly Friday,
it's front page news everywhere. Dow
is down two and a half percent. Very,
very dark. Then we start asking the questions we
should be asking Is this more transmissible? If
you get it, is it more likely to put you in the
hospital? If so, is it more likely to kill you?
Do the vaccines work like all the same questions
that we always ask? This time, the panic dialog
seemed to accelerate more quickly than in the
past, even though, as you pointed out on Twitter,
it's not really clear that the answers to those
questions really, really justify that. As far as
I'm understanding, as as of the conversation
you and I are having right now in 24 hours,
we may know more about it. What do you think is
going going on around Omicron specifically? Well.
Speaker 2: You know, like you, I follow
the news. I mean, the W.H.O. declared it
a variant of concern on the 26th. The first
reports were emerging in South Africa about
two weeks earlier in mid-November. Yeah. We know
from genomic analysis that the virus that this
variant probably first arose early October.
Plus, we know that from some epidemiology,
from some typical epidemiology. And so when, when,
when this sort of hit the popular consciousness on
on Friday, I wanted to take my time before I
offered any thoughts on the matter and not panic
and get a chance to review what what is known. And
we already know a fair amount about Omicron. We do
know in detail what's happening in South Africa.
We have a lot of genomic information. We have some
a lot of technical information about about about
these mutations because we've seen them in other
variants. We we have now some anecdotes around
the world of specific circumstances sort of, well,
you know, reasonably well studied situations.
You know this these two planeloads of people that
arrived in the Netherlands, 13 out of 600 people
were positive for Omicron. That gives you a little
bit of a hint as to the prevalence of the disease
in South Africa, so you can piece all these clues
together. Which took me some time to do. And,
you know, I have to form formulate a provisional
opinion as a November the 30th about Omicron. So
my opinion is that the that this variant probably
is roughly as transmissible to two somewhat more
transmissible than the Delta variant. It has a
it's more intrinsically infectious or
as intrinsically infectious as Delta,
approximately or slightly more intrinsically
infectious than Delta. I'm pretty confident about
that. So that's bad. The the hints in the data
are that it's probably not more deadly than Delta.
We don't know for sure. I'm not as confident
about that prediction. Yeah, but that's likely.
And on the so-called immune escape, you
know, does it evade the vaccines or not?
It's too early to tell. I think
it. It probably. Significantly.
Reduces the efficacy of the vaccine in terms of
spreading and somewhat reduces the efficacy of
the vaccine in terms of killing you. And but I'm
not confident about those assessments and it will
take a few weeks. Well, we'll get some hints
within a couple of weeks from in vitro studies
and then a couple of months or so before we begin
to see epidemiological studies that assess this.
So it's likely the Omicron variant
reduces the efficacy of the vaccines,
but by how much we don't know and against what
outcomes? Is it infection? Is it serious illness
or is it death? We don't know, and keep in mind
what we really care about is death. So if the if
if the variant reduces the ability of the vaccine
to keep you from becoming infected, that's bad,
but not the end of the world if you nevertheless
nevertheless fight off the infection. Sure. But
we really are curious about is, does that by how
much will the ONIKAN variant reduce the ability
of the vaccine to prevent you from dying? And and
that is unknown. It's clearly going to reduce it
some. But how much we don't know right now.
Speaker 1: Last thing when when you hear an
anecdote like some of the ones we're now hearing
about Omicron, I'm curious whether you even pay
any attention to it. The specific kind of
anecdote I read about today is in Hong Kong.
In a hotel, one person with Omicron opened the
door to accept room service, and the person across
the hall ended up getting sick. And of course,
you start imagining a cloud of Omicron droplets
somehow hanging, and when you hear something
like that, does it? Is that even actionable in
any way? Do you think about that at all?
Speaker 2: First of all, yes, OK,
I'm familiar with that case. In fact, I use I
put it in my Twitter thread and I studied it
from what's publicly known about it. Yeah, OK. In
early days like this one, we're like four days out
from it being declared a variant of concern.
You're looking at the tea leaves, right? You,
you get anecdotes like that and you look at all
the anecdotes that you can find and you try to get
a hint like, what is the behavior of this virus?
And that anecdote is consistent with a virus being
very infectious, right, that it's very easily
spreadable near. You have a quarantine hotel.
There are two travelers that are in quarantine
for two weeks. They're being tested every day or
every other day. They're testing negative. They're
testing negative. Then one of them test positive
and is whisked away to the hospital and then four
days later is across the door. A whole neighbor
test positive with the same variant, and they
trace it back, and they see that it appears to
have spread when when that first person briefly
opened their hotel room door unmasked and virus,
you know, spread across the hall. And by the
way, something similar happened in 2003 with the
SaaS one epidemic at a different hotel. This is I
discussed this case in detail in Apollo's Arrow.
It's a very, very famous case in epidemiology
at the Metropole Hotel in Hong Kong. Anyway,
so. So on the one hand, that anecdote,
you know, isn't going to specify global
policy. On the other hand, that anecdote
is consistent with the genomic data with
the early epidemiological data.
So in South Africa, consistent
with the idea that this disease spreads easily.
Speaker 1: And that is what we can take from it,
I guess at this point in time and not I mean, I
don't I don't know how much is known about that
example. Is it possible that the person providing
the room service might have been the link? I mean,
I just don't I just don't know enough about it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, that's correct. We don't we
don't know very much. That's exactly right. It's
a little bit like, you know, like again, you're
trying to, you know, you're trying to decipher
the intentions of our enemy, this virus. Yeah.
Based on the simplest of information and it
is early days still right? I mean, you know,
obviously within it. And again, this is to the
credit of our scientists and epidemiologists
and doctors and virologist and vaccinologist
like we have expertize in our society that is
deeply expert at exactly these topics. And I
guarantee you within a few weeks we will know
the answers to all these questions. And again, to
our credit, it's to the credit that we've invested
in training all of these people in spending money
to support the research. You know, with our tax
dollars, this is what we get. You know, and and
one of the things I find so weird is is that the
same people who are skeptical about all this
use this device, which also required lots of
scientists and engineers to make sure you're
Speaker 1: holding up your phone
for people who are listening. Yeah.
Speaker 2: Yes, I'm holding up my iPhone. How?
How do you think this device was
invented? The same kind of effort
that requires the invention of a vaccine. So
to use the iPhone to mock a vaccine is a bit
incoherent from the point of view of a science?
Speaker 1: Yeah, very much so. The book, now
in paperback, is Apollo's Arrow, The Profound
and Enduring Impact of Coronavirus on the Way
We Live. New Preface Afterword There's a number of
new elements. Yes. Yeah, we've been speaking with
the book's author, Nicholas Kristof. It's always
great having you on, I really appreciate it.
Speaker 2: David, thanks for having me
back. Good luck with your work. Thank you.